so here's why are here's my first piece
of evidence what's happening what's the
difference between my original function
this one which is the function X plus 2
and this one which is the function X
minus 2 okay well my first thought is
okay what we factorize why do we usually
factorize quadratics like what's the
point of factorizing what's useful
what's more useful about this fall then
this forum member i'm trying to get
towards a graph eventually right i want
a picture of what this looks like
there's a particular feature about the
quadratic that i can literally just read
off when I've got it in factorized form
whereas when I look at it in this form I
like mmm I really know what feature by
looking for what features aren't it the
exit two sets of the ones I've after
right the x-intercept I know what the
wine is it is it's just that guy right
but the X intercepts are not clear until
I factorize right what's your factorized
you can say and the other word for X
intercepts in this context the start of
an art in order but Ritz very good are
the roots I can read off for the
factorized form right there are two
roots what are they equal to yeah you
just take the opposite of these guys
right so negative 2 is the one I get
from here and negative 3 is what I get
from here okay so I'm just gonna write
them I'm gonna write them in ascending
order if that's okay right yeah question
ah it mathematics there is leaven things
that have much it except the chance a
probability but even that's not kind
budgets so we'll get to that in a second
man write down as you're just
established we can draw this in fact
like we have enough information to draw
this down remember I told you there's
your wireless sets and here are you at
two x-intercepts your roots let's just
quickly i asked you to draw up a set of
axes that's very very roughly sketch
this figure so five do it so i've got 83
and they gave two and then just next to
each other yeah question let's address
that question after we finish this is
that okay yep okay that all that mark
did is I just put in a bit of a scale
for myself and i think- through me about
their and negative 2 will be about there
okay the reason why I'm leaving several
spaces I can see I've got a few other
things to graph is gone and then if I
put six on here this is the vertical
access your solar one two three four
five six and that's roughly where I'm
expecting to go okay this isn't going to
be beautiful but I've seen a general
shape that's all I'm after so let's roll
asleep okay pretty new black
it's not the greatest but it'll do ok so
it's roughly a parabola it goes through
the three points that I'm interested in
that y intercept of these two
x-intercepts so far so good ok now let's
have a look kana let's have a look at
this guy down here right f of X plus 2
now you evaluate it you got to this
slide here now remember once you've got
it in this fall aha now I know what the
y-intercept is so it's just right there
it's 20 so in fact on my graph it's
probably going to be off the board
somewhere I'll p up you know if that's
six it's going to be about three times
higher further what are the roots what
are there is we can just read off the
roots right what are they looking for
yeah i get negative 4 from this one and
i get negative 5 from this one again
just like I did here I'm gonna write
them in ascending order okay so i've got
negative 5 and then you for ok now where
are they on my graph i'm going to put
this in a of a different color now ok so
i've got this graph I've been black my
original graph in fact I'll leave a
label this is y equals f of X and what
I'm about to put there is f of X plus 2
ok so excuse me the roots are of minus 5
minus 4 so here's a 02 then you 3 i'm
gonna move over this way right he is
negative 4 and here's negative 5 day
beautiful ok you can see if i'm going to
pass through these two roots and i'm
going to go all the way up here this
graph looks very very similar does it
not ok but in fact it's been um moved
over that way right let's see something
like this dish it has to do that kind of
thing right it's still facing up with
still a happy parabola concave up ok but
my roots are moved over this way and my
y-intercept is a bit high so I'm not
even going to draw it on there but I've
got the general shape ok
so that was f of X plus 2 now have a
look at our f of X minus 2 where the
roots where the rich 0 negative 1 good
from here I go to 0 and from here i get
negative 1 so again I'm going to put
them in ascending order negative 10 ok
so now I can pop in 0 sorry that's
negative 1 and 0 they're right by the
way you may have noticed i get for free
the y-intercept right because if one of
my writ 20 that's also the way it is
that yeah ok so let's just quickly draw
this guy in it's going to look like this
ok now we've got three wraps on their
right and they're all city one on top of
each other the first one I drew in black
which is y equals f of X the second
warlin which is over here is y equals f
of X plus 2 that's what you told me
about it right and then here is y equals
f of X minus 2 ok hmm what's happened
right well if you think about your black
graph is like the original graph ok when
you looked at this guy it's like the
same rat but it's it's moved right which
way is a move it's moved through the
left and when you have a look at the
last graph we drew the third one right f
of X minus 2 is also moved but it's gone
in the opposite direction has it it's
gone to the right so just gonna okay so
you can see we looked at the roots right
excuse me we use the roots to do a basic
graph and you can see this effect here
of putting it an extra number right of
extra constant inside that f of X
business it's all we've given a are it's
a translation right if you remember back
to a new server geometry you can modify
these you can transform them by either
translating reflecting or rotating right
translation reflection rotation
translation just means like slide it
back and forth it's the same shape it's
facing the same way but I just moved it
over this way or that way okay so here's
my first appeal to you and we will will
come up with like a big summary box of
this after but I moving to the left I'm
moving to the right and i'm using this
graph here okay